[Applause]
i think we have to talk about
jk rowling's yeah your girl they are
doing a 20th anniversary of the harry
potter movies yeah like a reunion
reunion on hbo max you know they did the
friends reunion they did a fresh prince
reunion they're gonna do one for harry
potters
but she is not gonna be a part of it and
she has not said why she will not say
why it seems but we're all assuming it's
because of her anti-trans tweets oh
and that bothers me okay just to me it
just don't have the reunion
like hbo is supposed to be so discerning
on the of the content they put out i've
heard if you have pictures of hbo god
knows what they buy they pass on so many
shows that end up being massive hits
yeah but
this they're gonna put on without the
person that wrote the entire story like
we don't give a [ __ ] about the actors in
harry potter's
like we weren't watching because we're
like dude this is so well acted oh the
direction is amazing we're like now
here's a fantastic story that's being
acted out by kids and they're doing a
pretty good job i guess but you can't
have a reunion without her just don't do
it or wait five years do it 25th i don't
know i am tuning in because i want to
listen to daniel radcliffe why because
i'm like oh they're the actors i like
these guys why have you ever when have
you ever listened to daniel what did you
listen to the friends reading to hear
what the writers had to say about no but
friends
that's the point friends was about the
characters it was about the acting it
was about everything you weren't looking
at daniel radcliffe like this kid is
knocking this out of the park yeah well
he's good for a kid
also this is this is about the movies
it's 20th anniversary of the movies yeah
and the the directors will be there the
characters
who are the directors
i can name them all
hey harry potter books is one [ __ ] dawg
they're not gonna have a party if
they're doing game of thrones you don't
mind me calling her [ __ ] because i'm
emphasizing her womanhood and that's
very important
game of thrones reunion do you need
ned stark to be there or do you need i
need george r martin in that [ __ ] you
want him to be there 100 percent
what are we [ __ ] talking about yo i
don't buy it bro
are you crazy what have you cared about
the writer of the thing being harry
dog
this [ __ ] a billionaire
why cuz she not famous in her own right
because she not responsible for all this
maybe miss the movie hey [ __ ] them kids
she just said she was just a producer
let me hey dana radcliffe [ __ ] you dog
[ __ ] you for not having her back what
about you she gave me she gave you nine
figures and you gonna sit here and [ __ ]
on her in public [ __ ] you emma watson
i'm glad you're single i can't trust you
[ __ ] nine figures
how much you worth how many minutes i've
done 100
i'll kill myself
if daniel radcliffe is worth a hundred
million dollars this goofy [ __ ]
kind of looked like a sketch on a book
and he made how much his net worth is
110 million [ __ ] you
[ __ ] you
and [ __ ] you
i agree with you i just said your point
can i be honest with you i i'm right now
i start to get hot on the inside of my
body so and he gonna sit here and
publicly trash this [ __ ] were you doing
more [ __ ] movies on tbs i genuinely
get out of here at all i genuinely mean
this
that person
is a piece of scum
wait why hey hey hey
hey
if a woman is responsible man or woman
if a person is responsible
for me making
110 million dollars and please believe
he's done nothing of notes since nor
does anybody give a flying [ __ ] about
him
since or will ever care about anything
else 100
got him 110 million dollars that is not
only wealth for him but well for
multiple generations after him okay his
family the radcliffe name
will will be different
from now on
because of this one woman
that's what i'm saying
you cannot criticize anything she says
you shut your mouth
your stupid [ __ ] mouth dog you gotta
agree with everything she says watson
that red-headed [ __ ] that we
haven't seen since
she got with her mind what if she goes
full nazis she's like i'm a nazi
sympathizer you gotta be like quiet just
keep quiet quiet i'm a sympathizer with
the nazi sympathizer i guess put 100
million dollars in my pocket i'm gonna
[ __ ] what you really gonna tell me we'll
give a permission on that one you say
this you say okay she went all nazi you
go you say this you say uh she got a
point
all right guys we're gonna take a break
from this exclusive patreon clip because
i got to tell you all about talk space
okay if you're going through anxiety
depression any sort of issue in your
life you need someone to talk to it
might be hard to talk to your family it
might be hard to talk to your friends
talk to someone at talk space okay you
can do it securely and privately i mean
this app is going to put you in a
private room with just you and your
therapist if you've never tried therapy
before hey imagine how easy it is when
you don't have to go to their office do
it over zoom do it over the phone it is
so convenient for you to talk through
the issues that you have with a
professional someone who's dealt with
this before and can get you into a much
better place in your life you can even
send messages 24 7 and get reprised
throughout the day no need to wait a
week for an appointment okay whether you
struggle with anxiety depression
self-doubt anything else talk space
gives you access to the health that you
need facing those obstacles is not easy
and you don't win a prize for doing it
alone get help get a professional and
the way you're going to do that is by
going to talkspace.com
and when you use our promo code flagrant
you're going to get 100 off your first
month when you use our promo code
flagrant at talkspace.com you get a
hundred dollars off that first month go
there now let's get back to this
exclusive patreon clip you can get the
whole episode at patreon.com flagrant
say well what do they do
exactly
no you say this you'd be like listen you
said you know how hard it is you're
asking me a question you know the right
answer to this question and you know by
giving the right answer i have to
criticize someone who has changed my
life and future generations of my life
okay i am so [ __ ] torn in this
situation and i'm gonna refuse to say
anything publicly about it i have my
personal feelings about that and then
i'm gonna keep those feelings perfect
i'll discuss it with them i'm gonna
discuss these conversations i discuss
with themselves exactly now she's not
coming out as a [ __ ] nazi okay that
is the craziest example and i understand
we have to jump to craziest examples so
that we can you know flush these ideas
out but she's not coming out as a
[ __ ] nazi right she's kind of being
pretty reasonable okay shut your [ __ ]
mouth kid
110 million dollars
i thought it was maybe 10 million you
don't know bro it went from like 150
grand to 3 million to like six the last
two movies they got 20 mil each and he
gets a piece of back end i'm sure i'm
sure that it is disgusting because from
the second that movie is a hit they
cannot do it without you do you know
what he said what do you say
i'm a probably stupid [ __ ] no no he said
uh he said uh what is it i believe any
women are women or some [ __ ] yeah pretty
much
you shut your mouth
and he said and he said something like
you have the quote right yeah he has
like a whole thing like a whole uh
i'm saddened at what she said and yeah
he's like certain press outlets have
asked me to speak on this blah blah blah
she's responsible for the course my life
has taken someone who's i've been
honored to work with and continue to
contribute to the trevor project blah
blah i feel compelled to say something
transgender women are women any
statement of the contrary raises the
identity of dignity of transgender
people blah blah blah [ __ ] you shut up
[ __ ] you shut your face you don't got no
career bro it's over
cellular [ __ ] action figures [ __ ]
[ __ ] little [ __ ] [ __ ]
i'm sitting here in my legs cross
calling you a [ __ ]
cause you the [ __ ]
yeah
yeah ron weasley he said something that
[ __ ] got nothing else going on
he was in lord of the rings no he quit
after that he like bought a ice cream
truck he just like he's cool hey she's
up ron weasley
hermione made the right choice dog what
did her body do they that's the got
married they got married
i don't really read that book brand like
what did the actual character do no that
[ __ ] trash she tweeted about it
no it's just disgusting man that's
disgusting there's no loyalty there's
none there's no it's disgusting no
that's disgusting she didn't write the
movies say what she didn't write the
movie [ __ ] movies she was actually
heavily involved in the movie making she
was producing and she insisted all the
actors be english so they could have
probably picked some [ __ ] american
kid but she didn't let him
it could have been emma stone could be
emma stone
going like that throughout every hijinx
how are we gonna get out of it
we're playing chess it's giant
[Music]
he's a three-headed dog
tarantula
a car's wine
oh point is [ __ ] y'all dude yeah that's
[ __ ] up [ __ ]
that's [ __ ] up i think we should
boycott it
i ain't watching it i think we should
boycott the [ __ ] queen in bruh 100
call her mommy that's mommy to you and
then apparently jk roy also got doxed
over the weekend
i bet it was emma watson trifling [ __ ]
but doesn't she have like a gated
community or something like that yeah
yeah yeah so she didn't get boxed
so basically people know she lives they
put her address out there like went to
her home and like took pictures in front
of it and like of it and then put it out
on twitter nice foul dude people
retweeting it
they got through the gates you tell my
gated community they're taking pictures
in front of the house no i think it's
more like some white house [ __ ] where
like you could take it in front of it
but in front of so far
i mean it's probably a big house yeah
she got land and [ __ ] you got gates come
on get out of here with that come on
stop it you're right they're putting her
address everywhere i mean it sucks but
you should have security for that which
you thought you could be a billionaire
and just like walk around and people
wouldn't want to come to your house
like no you have to get an island or
something like that get a moat
they should give her a herring haul
yeah that'd be dope yeah 100 then she
went over the top on twitter had like an
eight tweet thread basically being like
yo people can't this is the first tweet
i'll just read this one last friday my
family's address was posted on twitter
by three activist actors who took
pictures of themselves in front of our
house carefully positioning themselves
positioning themselves to ensure that
our address was visible
and then she's like thanks to everyone
that you know
got it taken down that tweeted at you
know conduct and standards blah blah and
then she this is the last tweet that she
says she says i've now received so many
death threats i could paper the house
with them and i haven't stopped speaking
out perhaps i'm just throwing this out
there the best way to prove your
movement isn't a threat to women is to
stop stalking harassing and threatening
us oh
that's a good ass point hey this [ __ ]
you're right yo
i told you you should be sticking
landings bruh yeah that's amazing
stickiness that was the last tweet too
that was loud
hey hey eight parts dog she'd be doing
in eighths
son she'd be killing them part eight
stones
that's a bad [ __ ] what up people you
just watch a clip from our weekly
patreon episode you can support the
flagrancy you can support this
unapologetic
unfiltered uncensored content that we
drop weekly on our patreon at
patreon.com flagrant2 you want to go
join
you should because it's a top 10 patreon
in the [ __ ] world that's right for a
good reason go check out why at
patreon.com flagrant2
all right peace
[Applause]